foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar entitled
neuropathology of stars Cove 2 as
revealed by spatial biology this webinar
is part of a lab Roots virtual event
series on the Coronavirus
I am Elizabeth Schneider senior Global
Marketing Manager at Nana sharing and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational webinar is presented
by labroots and sponsored by nanostring
for more information about manager and
you can go to our website
now let's get started before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
First participate by communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the president
you can find the live chat located at
the right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you would like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
uh if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the help desk
button located at the bottom of your
screen within the navigation bar or from
the lobby
and finally as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education credit
link located in the abstract window
below the presentation window and follow
the process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker Suzanne
krasman she is a group leader at The
Institute of neuropathology at the
University Medical Center Hamburg
eppendorf uke she's also the head of the
core facility of experimental pathology
or the mouse mouse patho lab
a little bit more about Suzanne she was
a neuron-centric focused researcher for
neurodegenerative diseases but it became
increasingly obvious in her work that
other brain types actively influence
disease processes
so the focus of our research is a study
of inflammatory profiles and
neurodegenerative disorders including
Alzheimer's and prion diseases
as the head of the core facility of
experimental pathology she performs high
resolution sceneing and imaging of
pathological tissue samples and its
Partners work she participated in
several projects to study viral diseases
such as lasso or Ebola and mouse models
and this obviously led her into the
study of pathogenesis of SARS Cove 2 in
Cova 19 especially in the brain two
years ago
and she has already published a couple
of manuscripts on source code to
abundance and their consequences in
several tissues and also her work that
she will be presenting today has also
come out in bioarchive and has the
distinction of being the hundredth
publication on the geomix digital
spatial profiling platform
so thank you so much Suzanne for being
here and thanks everyone for being on
the line to listen in
yeah thank you very much Elizabeth for
this very nice introduction and you
already introduced me so nicely so I
will directly start with my talk and
today I would like to talk about the
neuropathology of covid-19 because I
mean the thing is
um
of it
um as a name as a
disease of the lungs and it comes with
fever failure and cough and also with
like other signs of common cold but
frequently we also see neurologic
dysfunctions like the very common loss
of smell and taste but also more severe
things like seizures stroke and others
and also patients that had covid very
often suffer a neurologic problems such
as long covid with brain fog headache
but also again with more severe problems
so already very early into the pandemic
we ask um what's going on in the brain
and since um you all know that I'm
at The Institute of neuropathology in
hamburger we're obviously interested
about the neuropathology of the disease
and Hamburg
is a city body that's also an on State
and to get more information on the
pandemic the state asked the people from
the medicine to perform Odyssey so this
was done really via a quick law
and um thus here in Hamburg we had more
than 300 full autopsies of Kobe patients
since March 2020 and
um we in the Institute already
investigated more than 40 brains of
these patients
already early in the disease and
um this data I've already published so
we checked for common markers of that
you also have regulated or dysregulated
in neurodegenerative diseases such as
gfap which is a marker for astrocytes or
atrial ADR which is a marker of
microgliers innate immune system cells
of the brain or like cd8 which is a
marker for activated
fifth thirds and what you see here is um
that exercise do not play such a big
role obviously in covid-19 however for
the microglier we could see and this is
marked by the green arrows here and the
second column
um that we saw some nodules and also CDA
like T Cell wise we sometimes also saw
um t-shirts however when you check
um like
other brands of people that died of
independent courses then you also see
these kinds of
um like immune said so the question was
um how um specific was this for covid-19
and here you see an overview of the
patients that went into this study in
and the upper rule is astrocyte
activation the middle rows the
microgliosis and the lower rows the
cytopoxic these are um
infatuation or abundance and um to more
to the right side are the cases that
were positive for viral RNA and to the
left side you see cases that were
negative for virus while
um rtq PCR and when you check this table
you see that there's a lot of diversity
within the samples and there's not a
real Trend towards are there is
abundance of or there may be the
abundance of virus in the brain and more
severe pathology so we were really
wondering whether the changes that are
seen are more subtle
and that we also went into close-ups and
what we could see here and I already
mentioned this before that we saw this
microglial nodules or um areas where you
see um clusters of these um specific
immune cells
and applying an other marker which is um
CD 68 the marker for activated microglia
we saw that this is also
um
usually also a company Night by
activation and
but you could also see is that um this
cluster also are around
um methods so this was a question
whether and this was also one Theory
because the virus is um like distributed
via the bloodstream so obviously the
Linings of the weapons would be the
first Contact site for the brain
and so we were interested to see okay is
there anything going on with the vessels
in the brains of koi stations and
moreover we also very interested to see
whether there's really virus detectable
in the brain and for this
um
we
um were interested to
like establish a really reliable
staining for
um the ask of two infected test and we
started here with several cells that
were really artificially or in the lab
infected with Rask of two and these um
sets are here marked with red arrows
with always a wet column of the image as
infected cells and the left column are
then the uninfected cells and we tested
13 different antibodies against dark of
two
um against different proteins here there
were either directed against Spike
protein against non-structural protein 3
against the double standard RNA or
against nucleocapsive protein of South
Coast 2 as you can very easily see that
there are antibodies around that do not
show specific bindings to infected cells
then there were antibodies around that
also show
um High unspecific staining in the
uninfected cells but then there were
also cells or antibodies that work
nicely so what you would expect so
uninfected cells and this year are
formally fixed paraffin embedded so the
same way as we would fix
um also tissue samples
um and so
um we thought okay these antibodies that
are marked with a green circle here
would be suitable because they do not
show any staining in unaffected set but
show really high reactivity in the
infected somebody and with this we went
to Long tissue
and only focused on the antibodies that
already worked in our cell-based system
and again here we could see that some
antibodies performed better than others
and here um the infected or the the lung
tissue from per person with some
covid-19 is marked and wet and lung
tissue from like a non
um covet patient is non-labeled so you
see that again some antibodies work
nicely some Produce High background and
some do not produce specific staining
but what was also obvious is that
obviously antibodies directed against
Spike protein showed less signal than
those of nucleocapsid protein and
um
I'll give a um and one of other point is
and here's an example of a respiratory
mucosa that
um the presentation of infected sets as
rather with a planar station and
staining and not with the punctuate
staining as might
be in some Publications but to further
evaluate
um
um the
like
um specificity of the spike antibodies
we also used other Spike antibodies that
are directed against the receptor
binding domain against S1 and the
antibodies that are already stored was
against S2 in contrast to the monoclonal
and here again in the cell system
they seem to work like equally good but
here again in the lung and these are
consecutive sections of lung tissue we
again could see that the abundance of
Spike proteins much less than
nucleocapsid protein and this lettuce
also to assume that detection of nuclear
capsued is much more well suited for the
detection of infected cells that is
Spike protein here and because you
detect rather more cells with nucleocaps
it directed antibodies and this could be
further evaluated in infected viruses in
the upper wall again respiratory mucosa
and lung from a patient that died of
covid-19 and again here
and he said and we could see that spike
is much less and so our staining were
usually then performed with nuclear
capsid
um directed antibodies and here's an
example of lung tissue and you really
see how heterogeneous the picture is in
a tissue where everybody thinks Ayah
this is the main target of the disease
so there should be tons of virus and
believe me this is not always the case
because also these are examples of
patients that died of sarcoph2 so um
there might be only single cells
infected even in lung tissue
and furthermore
um like tissue from people that might
also have immune activation and other
Australia is prone to
um
so I'm not really background staining
but artifact
um in the tissue that might look like
that's cause II and these are labeled by
errors here in wet Y and you see that
there might be precipitates from the
antibodies you see that there might be
other precipitate that looks like the
husk of poop but or not and even if you
go to control tissue and this is also
something
that we really investigated in great
detail you see that also and people from
really uninfected patients that also
came to make a tour from like 2018 or 19
before
um
pandemic started you see that there are
some backgrounds so we were very
cautious
um to really
um
be able to State what we see is what we
think is the ask of tool and um we again
went to SAR model and here are viruses
which are highly susceptible
um for that cost when you see um like
lots of um infected cells and if you go
to the um
human cell line it's like a tumor cell
lines so it's not a super good model for
neurons but we could see that at least
um some cells could be infected and I
have to say um
the efficiency is much less than in the
vehicle sets
um but this this is knowledge we then
went to the brain and we saw said that
the might
um really um carries ask of two
um in the medulla of persons that died
with South Coast 2 however
the abundance of virus positive cells
were super low and we only rarely saw a
single infected sets however
um you know
um these patients they are not with
acute covid-19 but they had coveted 19
so
um this might be also a fact that we
since we do not acute disease that we
might also obviously Miss on some sides
so but what is known as there are
several putative Pathways
um of the ask of two into the brain and
one we investigated already in our
manuscript so sarskov school might also
from the lung might come via for example
vagus nerves
um to the
um
medulla or the spinal cord to the
respiratory Center
so this would be one option the other is
obviously that
um since the virus is also infecting the
nasal epithelium it might also traveling
to the
um a factory pipe however
manuscripts out there that favor this
infection Roots but there are also
others that think that this might not
um the case or um and it's still even
after more than two years into the
pandemic
um
still not not super nicely characterized
but also the blood brain barrier as I
already pointed out might be a good
entry side
um or for for that cuff too and it might
also lead to a weather dysfunction
so that was also one of our questions so
is there a really bloodline barrier
infection or is it just dysfunction
because of over activation of the immune
system and we first stained with the
common marker which has become one or
three
61 in covid-19 and controls and when we
Quantified this we could see that
there's no obvious like over difference
in the results in in covid-19
um
so we wanted to look more closer to the
records unfortunately
um I won
a nano string grant for the tomb X atsp
Program so I could
um like work on this digital special
profiling which was a super nice
opportunity for us and since you work
with like slides and as you usually do
um for your paraffin sections and for
your tissue analysis
I was invited to
um provide two slides so to um gain the
maximum input what we did is so we took
regions and here are some paraffin
blocks and with Point tissue samples and
did punches and then we did um like
punches and made
um like this um
um multiple multiple array
um blocks to get over six punches
on one slide and provide two slides
so we provide examples of seven Copic
brains and the five control points and
um so we could select 48 vessels and to
sum up this process so first we
um our Nano string stains slides with
antibody of my choice and hybridized
with an expression library then I could
digitally
really like live online select the
regions where I was in interested most
so I checked um likes and selected
specific vessels which I will show you
on the next slide and only in this area
so oligos were cliffed off and then they
were sequenced so we only got the
sequence of this and I specifically used
markers for exercise whistles and immune
sets and DNA as a morphology marker to
see the nuclear and here is um and the
overview how this looks then and if you
go on closer it was especially nice
because in in yellow uh um you could see
very nice with the vessels which are
also like labeled here and we
specifically shows vessels which did not
show so much immune activation because
we really were interested in the
epithelial cells and not in the immune
cells and
these are some examples and how the
regions of its interests and looked like
and where these oligos were sucked often
and as I told you we selected 48 vessels
and
then we compared the expression profiles
and we could really see that certain
clusters were specifically upregulated
in covid-19 and
um
because it's also depicted here and this
heat map that really a couple of genes
um were upregulated and these clusters
especially in groups um that were
associated with antigen processing and
also with interferon gamma signaling
um which we thought is super interesting
um and so these covet patients really
clustered together and
um
we
um then wanted to
um confirm this further and we are so um
did qpcr on ethaphone gamma
um pathway related genes if you TM um
one and two and there were significantly
increased here also in our patients and
either the staining on ectm2 and we
matched these with patients of the same
age to really
try to
pull out like sampling effects effects
in in the age and it was really super
nice that we could also see that if it
tm2 is really specific to the weapons
and this we bond to explore further
that's um we teamed up on this ulaplace
from fraunhofer Institute and he just
established a very Advanced Brain
barrier model
of a human ipsc cells where we really
have a tight monolayer
um
where unlike liquid substances cannot
pass and we added task of tools so to
the upper wall so this is really
resembling The Vessel Loom via
the whether the lower compartment is
resembling the brain pattern timer and
we wonder whether this cells could get
infected
and um also performing
immunofluorescence analysis here for
Spike and nuclear capsid protein we
could see that these cells could indeed
be infected however the abundance was
not super high so it was around 0.5
percent
um
and um here is an overview of how it
looked so you again see that not many
sets get infected this is here after 24
hours and we also did several um
[Music]
um
um infection and infections with
different virus titles and we also used
um different viral isolates just to see
whether there's a specific effect on
this but um it was not so we always
ended up with about 0.5 percent infected
cells and but what we were wondering
whether we could also see a replication
in our cells and this is also
um
um what's the like investigated by
immunofluorescent staining with two
other markers
um non-structural protein three which
might be a marker for application
however the other stranded RNA is only
forming
um if the virus is actively replicating
and indeed we could see in the set that
also shown nuclear capsid protein
High abundance of this double stranded
RNA then we would also see is release of
virus to the lower compartment so we saw
an increase here on on virus
um
so we were wondering
um are these sets like like leaking or
maybe the blood brain barrier is not
tight um anymore so um the virus can
pass through the pericellular spaces and
to reach this patholateral compartment
of the cells and for this we did
electron microscopy on cross-sections of
our blood brain barrier cells so again
there were infected from the uppercut
side so it's no wonder that we also see
virus attached to this area but we also
detected virus in the basilateral
compartment
below you can still see the membrane
where the sets were growing on
and to investigate whether the like the
black brain barrier function was still
intact we added um fluorescent dye to
the upper compartment and then measured
if these um dye is leaking to the lower
compartment and indeed after the last of
two infection it was not so um we think
that these cells indeed might also
release virus to the lower compartment
which would then resemble the brain
parenchyma so in theory
um this could mean that these
endothelial cells of the blood brain
barrier could pass
um task of to enter the brain and we
were also interested
um whether these sets then show the
inflammatory profile
that we detected with the Nano string
DSP analysis in the brains as the covet
patients and we perform two pcrs or for
the interferon gamma related pathway
genes and indeed and we could also see
significant upper regulation
in our cells
and this was interesting because I mean
if you do the DSP in the brain
you also might
grab this like for example astrocyte and
feeds or
also investigate just by chance um one
or the other inflammatory cell
but this year was a pure
um like ipsc model so there were no in
immune sets um in this essay so and this
was interesting that and the Celia said
by themselves
um Can acquire an inflammatory profile
um by infection and buy contact with
South Coast too
um
yeah
um so we were also interested
um to check upon the receptors and we
could see that the main or the main
receptors mainly like Ace 2 but also
nrp1 and the co-receptor tampers 2 where
indeed also infected in the blood brain
various sites and we were also
interested to see whether this could be
used for pharmacological interventions
um
and so we used different methods so we
used an anti-spike
antibody we used anti-ace2 antibodies
anti-nrp1 antibodies and nakamostat
which is a temper is two small inhibitor
and interestingly as you can see from
the immunofluorescence pictures here in
an anti-spike antibody so an antibody
which is like virtually covering
um the the virus really lateral complete
um blockage of infection
whereas ace2 and the thermostat
had very good results in reducing the
amount of infection and also NRP one
reduce infection but given the abundance
of the different receptors and I mean
also aced with abundant it is a very low
and still um blocking this receptor was
highly efficient as you can see on this
quantification here so this is also
really a point that even tells that only
expressed very low amounts of ace2 might
be for one thing susceptible for the
infection but might be odd so saved by a
pharmacological interventions
and to sum up everything so we showed
that in theory
um like endothelial cells could be and
can be infected and they could pass
um the virus um to the other side so um
the putative
brain parenchyma
um
however
um even if this might not be
um the effect in Vivo I'm still
has an effect on the expression profile
of the endothelial layer namely an upper
regulation of the interview on gamma
pathway which could be targeted also
um
effectors that block viral entry
and as Elizabeth
um already
mentioned our manuscript is the hundreds
manuscript with nanostring
um
special profiling so sorry so um so very
nice and um to sum up as I said so the
spacer transcriptal mixture that we have
a regulation of the interferon gamma
pathway and covid-19 patients in the
neuroascular unit and this can be also
seen in the
ipsc derived brain capillary endosilian
cells when they are infected with task
of two task of two can replicate in
these cells and can to like release
virus to the basil lateral
um side and this can be inhibited by
several means like antibodies but of the
small inhibitors
um
but still we do not know much about the
long-term consequences of zaskov II and
so really a lot more research is
necessary and a lot more to really
understand if sarskoff 2 is really
entering the brain how it is entering
the brain and and how the abundance or
the distribution might be in the brain
or alternatively
um
how cells are altered in the brain by
either direct infection or contact with
sarskoff to or contact this immune set
so there's a lot to do and also since a
lot of people also now with the American
variant
and I'm talking not about literature
here but also on life experiences
um with colleagues and friends that this
really quite common
after infection even in mild infections
that you
are more forgetful that you are very
easily tiring
that you feel like
um easily dizzy
after infection so it's really worth to
study these effects in more detail and
with this I would like to thank my
collaborators and the neuropathology
[Music]
um
which are mainly Christine Hartmann and
other teeth and I would like to thank
all the plus from farnhofer
and his the collaboration with a super
nice black brain barrier model but other
also other collaborators in the uke like
the Vanessa and Fabian Heinrich other
co-workers in charity and I would also
like to thank Nano string
for giving me this nice Grant to perform
the
special profiling in the covid-19 race
because it really paid and we have now a
much better
um idea what's going on in the brains
and yeah
now we are open for your questions thank
you very much
hello everyone thank you for watching
the webinar presentation so now it's
time for the live q a and I know that
you have a lot of questions that you're
dying to ask Dr Crossman so um please go
ahead and submit your questions through
the Q a window
um and we will commence the Q a
I actually have a question for you to
kind of uh kick things off
um what is the next step in in your
research in this particular project
well that's uh actually a good question
so there are a lot of things we we still
really do not know so
um one obvious thing is
um I mean we we rather did not directly
detect virus in vessels in our patient
campus
and I mean it's a like special cohort
since this is uh all a patients that um
often had long duration time so
obviously
um everything that had happened might
not be visible at this time point so
what we really would like to do is also
um to investigate more brain areas so
until now we focus certain areas like a
factory bulb which is also the obvious
entry route from like the nasal cavity
and so Factory mucusa we investigated
medulla oblongata because this is
obvious
um part if you think that um
virus could enter the brain via the
survivorous nerve so it's also I mean we
are like focusing on the blood brain
barrier but this we are not restricted
to it so um I would really like to check
other areas that are not so like obvious
and um
investigate these because I mean we have
some material there and it would be very
interesting also now that we have and
there are also like papers coming in
like every day
um on covet
um we know some genes that are up
regulated so this would also be maybe a
good starting point to check for these
genes if they are expressed at specific
locations within the brain and to then
start out the search in this area there
was just
um I think some days ago also a very
nice take for about
neuronal process degeneration in the
factory bulb and kovit source is
something that even after like more than
two years people did not
um
and detect yet so I mean they used also
very nice techniques um and I think
there's still a lot to do
okay it looks like we had a question
come in
um
uh does stars Cove 2 increase protein
aggregates in the brain
uh that's a good question
however we I mean we only have focused
on some foreign areas so far but these
do not show like protein aggregates and
I think it's really difficult to tell
um that's probably something
um
we would rather expect after after like
long covet or so because also like
aggregation of proteins in the brain
takes time
and what we know yet is that there's
also an up regulation of immune
infiltrates it's not in all patients but
in some and other regulation of um like
brain immune cell activity is also going
hand in hand with um like other things
like um type of kinds and maybe also
more phagocytosis or maybe also
um
more aberrant pruning of neurons also
and I could imagine that this could
maybe Ultra protein aggregates in the
brain or maybe just um speed up
um what is already so like in the pre
um dementia phase they are also already
Aggregates in the brain however these
people do not have dementia yet and
maybe this immune activation might speed
up this processes so I can can think of
this also to study this and in future
approaches definitely interesting
thanks and that's a great great question
um yep
um would anyone else like to ask your
question
now now is your chance
so we had another question come in um
have you thought about doing any single
cell
um sequencing studies or any single cell
spatial analysis
[Music]
um
that's also a very good question
but no we have not
um
it's also
a problem after sampling process
so um I mean in Germany it's also a very
strict rule how to to handle courses and
as I said in the beginning of the talk
in the beginning of the pandemic the
city of Hamburg so the state really
ordered autopsy
to try and or in the in the wish to try
to understand more what's happening in
this severe covid-19 cases and there are
more we are also for modern time but now
it's rather also difficult to get
autopsies done on on Copic patients
because it's an like unfortunately it's
so common
um and I think this is a big obstacle
especially
um like in Germany so for smart and
times increase now we usually have like
two to three to five days now don't
think that this is a
um a very good prerequisite um to do a
thing as hell but it would be super
interesting yes I agree but there's a
nice story out from the viscore lab
where they did um this it's not single
cell it's single noxic
um and it's also
only focusing on some brain regions but
it was published I think November or
December
2021 and this is really really nice
story I can only recommend reading it
great we had another question come in
after all the testing that you performed
for Spike and nucleocapsid for
antibodies do you have a couple that you
could recommend
oh yeah I have um
so
um we currently I'm in f as you may have
seen we currently have a manuscript on
this in in revision and
um what we like really realize is that I
mean that's also obvious from the virus
life cycle
um that's abundant of nuclear capsid
protein in an infected cell is much
higher than the abundance of Spike
protein and this is not only visible in
like freshly infected hairs this is also
visible in all the tissues that we
started for the abundance of virus
infected cells and viral proteins so I
can only recommend nuclear capsid
um antibodies because they give a much
better signal to noise ratio and um here
I mean there are several that I could
recommend there are some one um from
I think it's you know biology it's
called mm05 that's a mouse monoclonal
that's very good and another company
synaptic system has two
um
anti-nucleocapsin antibodies in their
portfolio and they really work nicely
and we already tested them on different
variants of concerns including like a
data and then also including Omicron and
also here Spike protein antibodies often
failed because of the variability of the
spike but this nucleocapsid protein as I
said from synaptic systems really did a
like a very good job
excellent so another question
um that came in does SARS CO2 infection
influence the glucose uptake by the
brain
oh that's a very good question
um but we have not investigated this I
mean so I I cannot I can't really tell
you but I think it's a super interesting
question and people should definitely
um check it because it might also tell
you
um about weather disturbances and about
what might happen also in Long Cove it
maybe there's also some metabolic
problems and arising in the brain and
this would be definitely interesting to
study
foreign
thanks uh another question what happens
to drug e-fluxing Transporters in the
blood-brain barrier during SARS CO2
infection awesome an excellent question
but we have not studied yet
um this so I
um as you may have seen I
um to study
um the groin barrier in in vitro I
teamed up from with all the plats from
fraunhofer Institute here in Hamburg and
um
we are currently thinking of different
things that we would like to study in
this in vitro system before we actually
then go again to the brain
and um I think this would definitely be
something to study more and also what we
see and um this was also I mean you
might recall the images that I showed
that if you have like um the blood-brain
barrier model there are only subsets and
factored in this even in this model and
this also if you take increasing amounts
of hours this is also like saturating so
it's not that you can increase and
increase and increase the amount of fat
so it would be also interesting to check
whether this specific cell also have a
certain profile so coming back also to
the Single Cell experiments
um maybe this would be a more like
um easy to Target
um approach and um
will also tell you something about this
molecular or
um events that then are taking place in
in these cells
excellent thank you for that question
so we're wrapping up here um if anyone
has any additional questions they'd like
to ask feel free to get them in now
um if we don't get a chance to address
your questions then we will follow up
individually with each of you so I'll
give a couple minutes for last minute
questions to get in
all right I think that concludes the Q a
portion of the webinar so thank you so
much Suzanne it was a pleasure um to
have you speak and thank you to everyone
um who attended and listened to your
talk
okay thank you for like um listening to
the talk and um bye bye see you again
bye thank you bye